this movie you have like right off the
value of an all-star cast of comedians
and you know we heard that David Spade
was coming at seven days he wasn't
emailing the call she just to hang out
what was the atmosphere like on sand it
was crazy
every day is like wait that's that
that's every day is I was like there is
no one that Adam Sandler cannot get to
like one day is Jay Leno then it's like
I could do you got vanilla ice the you
guys just like everybody in all areas of
the industry enemy coming through and at
one point when you read it in the script
is like no are this really going to be
in here and then they were yeah we
expect now right after that words of
people who slowly kept um well by the
script yeah yeah I mean it said it
anybody's like I'm really going to be in
it you know and turns out like and then
more and more kept getting at it looks
like all Adam and the movie your
characters well Courtney's like um she's
most comfortable on stage singing
mmm-hmm can you relate to that at all is
that kind of how you feel
yeah I can relate to a lot of things
with Courtney Clark you know but I guess
it's just like the true performer you
know because I feel that way like I
always get nervous in the wings of the
stage but soon as I step on the stage
I'm at home and I kind of feel like it's
the same for Courtney as well yes um the
basis of the story is obviously a love
story um you know Courtney gets swept
off her feet she seems like in it in a
certain way or hopeless romantic yeah
who falls in love with this very
unlikely character are you hopeless
romantic yourself not all things I'm
free and that way her - exactly
no not at all yeah I don't even think I
even know what that means to be honest
really know what does it what does love
mean to you oh that's another subject
um I don't know the answer to that
question okay okay yeah there's Jennifer
now back okay there's also um you know
you instagrammed a moment of yourself
with sandy Wexler on the big screen in
time
and I wonder at this point in your life
when you've achieved so much you argue
Instagram I guess you're going to say in
the video
yes yeah you still those pinch yourself
moments you're like this is actually
amazing yeah because let me tell you why
because you know when you do this you
never really get to see it so if someone
don't send it to you or let you know
about that you have no way to tell and
it's like okay you do all the work and
do all the work and then it's like you
never get to see it so when I do get to
see those moments I still get excited
and it's a feeling that you can never
really get used to every second I don't
take anything lightly or for granted you
know speaking of feelings she gets
discovered Korda gets discovered in an
amusement park you still remember the
first time that you got discovered and
what that feeling was like oh my god I
feel like that was the start of it
because I used to work for Disney and I
used to sing on a cruise ship which is
very similar to Cortney sing in an
amusement park and it was there that my
Disney director he took me out of that
and became my manager so it's kind of
similar to Cortney story and that's kind
of my start right there you know and so
I definitely connected that you know
with Cortney and Sandy did you think at
that time that that would be a gateway
when you first got that job singing for
Disney did you think this could be my
opportunity to showcase town stuff would
get me where I want to be you know what
I took my Disney experience I use it as
a test I said if I can get through this
[ __ ] in this contract and do what I love
then I'm cut out to go audition for show
like American Idol but if I can't then
jump so you need to go home don't even
bother to go but I made it through it
and so when I took that job it I got to
learn so much as a performer and it
prepared me like helped prepare me for
the industry and that's when the ball
really started rolling for me and I knew
the moment I stepped on this ship I was
like I'm never going to be at home for
good ever again and I haven't been
assisted what gives you a sense of home
having said a sense of home it's the
same thing I always say to my son is
this like keeping it famiglia 'no
surround me you know me like everywhere
i go i carry the blankets we sleep with
at home you know and that way it still
feels
my bed at home or I still smell the
sense of my child you know and stuff
like that and and it's just a matter of
taking home with me and my family yes
you mentioned American Idol okay and
it's kind of ironic that you lost an
American Idol but yet one is a judge Wow
Wow
I'm UK the voice Wow do you know what
I've noticed that same thing I look like
okay so this doesn't mean I kind of won
so what I'm glad that I felt like I
didn't win Idol but then I turn around
and when the voice on my first try so I
take that Conda as a win but um what
exactly I felt like it made it more
relatable for me like I could relate to
the contestants that much more and I
think that's what helped me win too
because I was one for contestant on a
show like this so I kind of had a
different perspective and then now being
in the industry like okay it's two sides
to this coin now that we strategize and
figure out how to approach the thing and
I did it I've learned all I said yes
thank you thank you was that you
mentioned your son - what was it like
having him on I know we did something a
while back there's footage that made its
way through the office of your son when
you're getting your star on the Walk of
Fame and he was like the dancer she is
he is and he wasn't shy what the camera
at all wanting having him on the show
and being able to kind of share those
moments with him what's that like I love
it I love being able to just catch him
exposed to just my world and also his
dad's world you know like he's exposed
to so much and which makes us very
curious to see like what is he going to
gravitate to right now he's into dancing
and singing and but you know it changes
pieces each age for kids so it's like
each year alike okay is this what he's
going to be is this who he is and when
we were in the UK doing the UK voice he
would dance and entertain the audience
during the commercial breaks so that's
helping him come out of his shell and
not be so shy and he's turned into a
performer himself
yeah did you learn anything about
comedic timing I look at I look at you
know this post area look at his space
around I just wonder do you
anything from someone has such great
comedic timing yeah I mean this whole
thing was so new and different and like
I'm always an emotional actress where I
realize is easier to play dramatic roles
emotional roles the comedic part is a
little bit more challenging in a way you
need to be able to bring the humor the
energy that's needed but I'm glad I had
a good coach which is Adam so you know
and it was cool to work with him as an
actor / director I've never done it
before where I'm working with the
director and the actor and at times it's
like I always had to stay on my toes
like okay Who am I Who am I faces Adam
right now the director or is this Andy
and he'll come out of character and say
okay let's try this so I had to be able
to roll with him you know and like live
in that moment so he's not the most
attractive character in this movie in
addition I know sometimes kissing scenes
could be awkward how awkward was that in
addition to how unattractive his
character oh my god what am i what
singing and his wife is on stage with
the kids is Ron say just to add just to
add to the whole atmosphere oh my god
hmm um Wow what can I say to that how
would I turn it around in the channel
right okay so first of all sandy is such
an adorable character like you can't
help but to love them and you see his
heart you know and that's what saying if
that's what Kourtney fell in love with
Sandy's heart and when you're lost in
the character you forget about who's
there who's watching and it's not
Jennifer it's my Adam it's Kourtney and
sandy now who had a problem with it was
my son he's like ah and Adams little
girls like so wait dad so you have to
kiss her and as I well he wrote it in
the script it wasn't me but you know
it's a part of the job I think one of
the most amazing parts is um you know
ten years ago you did Dreamgirls
Oscar you know sag one of multitude of
awards and here you are in feathers
singing in this movie ah it's like
expositions amazing do you appreciate
that about being able to act yes that's
the thing I love most it's just to be
able to stretch and I've always wanted
to do a comedy I would have never
guessed that I would get to do it with
such a legend like Adam Sandler in the
project like this so it's allowing me to
show other sides of myself as an actress
so yes I love being in the dark customs